you put that into your movement you'll
realize that
um I'm here
yes it's still not doing it see you're
still your mind is still forward yeah
where it's got to have that pulling back
Sensation that was
better for
you were thinking you were thinking
forward as well
yeah yeah you're still thinking forward
so you're looking at him and you're
thinking forward but you want to
think don't Place p in your hand think
what you thought
[Music]
this yeah we just did
that
yeah to much and that's a bit rude of me
again is this your oh yeah yeah yeah
should right so so you're going to
you're going to think that you got Joe
you
all right so you what I want you to do
is do a high
Gish getting G see what I mean yeah stri
his knee so then strike his
knee that's it so he's going to then cut
that he's going to you're going to cut
to his head you're going to do the get
movement he's going to then
cut and he's going to go cut you go to
the other side and
okay now you're in the same footwork as
at the end with the can
oh
yeah yeah and again you've got to be
drawn with the Massi
that's better see now we're getting
right angles the end of the hyub not
form
am I
doing
yeah NE
[Music]
see so you're in the right
angles
you so keep going and I'm going to over
talk the point is we must make the Ken
and Joe feel the same because they
should be extensions of our body so they
extensions of our body then uh shouldn't
become a sort of separate item within
their
s so where we've got a problem here
is earlier when I said you cut the neck
and then you go onto the
hands I said the lift is too big away
from
the
roll going to break this down in slow
motion first part is
to his
head now he does the
getm movement here comes
in do the same
again so at this point this is where
it's wrong because you'll notice if you
watch the tip of the Jael he's taking it
away
from long and he mustn't take it away if
we were doing the K work so if we were
doing the K work would have to blow to B
with the tip of his jaw and he goes yes
he
goes under his
jaw then it makes it a
we so he go to his J rather
than so it's like a last minute quick
movement at the right moment
under
the so can you see again
there
here but this means that all this isn't
it here I just walk under
my I take it
away I only take it it's a c and I
easing eing out of that I'm here if I do
this you got lots
of if I'm here and I go here and he's
waiting he can see
I'm still not ready so
I I
start just the rest ising pretty
good for